so cool wenn er in der bahn steht so ich
krieg das nicht hin ich versuche schon
die ganze fucking zahl dieses seven
nation army irgendwie auf der ukulele
hinzu kam ich schaff's einfach nicht das
kann einfach nur sturm waffel naja gut
herzlich willkommen hier erst meine
lieben freunde zu einem spiel habe ich
jetzt geklatscht dieses spieles mal so
ein bisschen was anderes und zwar heißt
spiel shakes and fidget also zu deutsch
übersetzt zappeln und sie dann
es ist auf jeden fall will ich gerne das
habe ich mir nicht gedacht ich habe
eigentlich nichts was ich entschuldige
mich jetzt schon für den anfang dieses
videos ist es immer wieder total
chaotisch ich habe mir gedacht da ich ja
sonst immer so spiele spiele die so
klein sind und dann passiert da nicht
viel und dann ist das auch so ne story
und so können wir heute noch so ein
bisschen was anderes jemand dann habe
ich mich manchmal gewünscht von ein paar
leuten dann spielen das ganze mal ich
habe um ehrlich zu sein dieses spiel
zwar schon mal davon gehört aber es noch
nie gespielt wikipedia sagt zu dem spiel
im spiel kann man in der tabelle quests
annehmen deren erfüllung dem spieler
erfahrungspunkte und geld einbringen ihn
aber abenteuerlust kosten weiterhin
weiterhin als weiterhin kann spieler in
der taverne bier zur steigerung der
abenteuerlust trinken und beim
hütchenspiel um gold und pilze spiel
hier trinken bier trinken direkt in die
taverne in der taverne kannst du
auftraggeber trunkenbold und allerlei
halunken antreffen
immerhin hat man denn hier wurde das wir
möchten wir sag mal kumpel willst du
dich erst mal was tun bevor du dich hier
mein geschäft macht müde helden munter
du siehst im moment weder besonders müde
noch wie ein held aus sprich mal jemand
anderen ihr anders bestimmt eine aufgabe
für als ob das spiel richtig behindert
du kannst nicht trinken du hast ein
bisschen moment knochen der meine
aufträge sind nichts für schwächlinge
muss leider wieder gehen das tut mir
natürlich leid dir an was es zu tun gibt
aber wenn du angst hast dann lass es
liebe
bleiben wähler ein abenteuer i mag die
goldene truhe eine million münzen
erfahrung 618 dauert 20 minuten gibt so
etwas kürzeres sei jetzt verstehe ich
auch wie das mit der abenteuerlust
funktioniert das geht 20 minuten das
heißt abenteuerlust kannst du auch
antrinken frage dem barkeeper wenn wir
nichts geben aber wenn das hier dort
beispielsweise fünf minuten geht nur
fünf abenteuerlust machen wir das ganze
noch mal selbst ja genau du ich habe
versucht sich hinterrücks zu ermorden
und dabei alle meine pfeile verschossen
jetzt brauche ich neue reise durch die
sonnenbrand wüste sammeln nebenrollen
mindestens sieben und kehre dann zu mir
zurück nicht vergessen schlechte kunde
wir tat bestraft durch die sonnenbrand
wüste das auf jeden fall auch ein name
ja wo sind denn hier pfeiler ich muss
irgendwo feile finden aber nicht
vergrößert mach mal hier
wo sind denn und ist an jeden fall da wo
können die denn sein wie mache ich das
dann überhaupt hier sind work sind in
der pfeile
er hat eine welche man eine blöde quelle
/ tiscon crafter 64 euro
command gewissen oder pakistan minecraft
albert geplänkel blödmann abbrechen
es geht einmal ich habe einfach keine
pfeile gefunden wer gewinnen will muss
eben auch etwas riskieren das ist sehr
vernünftig von euch komme ich mache
wieviel setzt sich denn nicht mal ich
selbst mal fünf millionen pilze setze
ich mal auch drei sätzen und los und was
ist jetzt da da daniel mein glückwunsch
ihr kennt euch hoffentlich gute diesem
spiel aus versucht es am besten gleich
nach jetzt ohne was was muss ich denn
jetzt hier machen
ich verstehe die sache mit denen den
quests nicht kann sein dass es einfach
lädt neun minuten oder ich weiß
ich weiß ich weiß wie es läuft ich weiß
wie es funktioniert mama ich weiß nicht
funktioniert das ist gar nicht so dass
ich irgendwas suchen muss ich muss
einfach abwarten stimmen das ist ja so
ähnlich wie bei diesen anderen spielen
auch diese strategie mäßig sind du musst
ja einfach warten stimmen der linie
quest machen will muss ich einfach
erwarten wären wir jetzt zehn minuten
genüsslich warten und das video hat
dahinplätschert habe ich aber noch was
anderes zu sagen und zwar war racer sehr
sehr lieb und die haben mir drei
kopfhörer zugeschickte sind diese racer
sind das aber eher wie genau heißen die
nochmal jedenfalls schreibe ich eine
beschreibung was für ein ding ist da
könnt ihr dann auf die website gehen und
die kaufen oder halt nicht ich werde
nicht dafür bezahlt dass das machen nur
die bahn halt so niemann haben wir drei
stück zugesendet ein paar für mich und
zwei für euch das heißt wenn ihr solche
kopfhörer haben wollte die sind ganz
cool die könnt ihr euch so aufsetzen
wow ich einfach gar nichts mehr das ist
krass dass der pächter aus wie sondern
wie dieser eine dj mit denen jeder jet
kopfhörer aber dieser eine mit den
dicken egal jedenfalls wenn ihr die auch
haben wollt dann schreibt einfach mal in
die kommentare
lieblingsessen und warum ihr damit die
kopfhörer einschmieren was halt einfach
mal euer lieblings es in die kommentare
und der der das dann macht der das auch
macht er dann dann suche ich davon zwei
aus und die haben dann da vielleicht ich
gehe mal aufs neue kleider gezeigt die
stufe deiner kann auch an der legende
nach hilft die arkane aura hat gesottene
händler zu beeindrucken und als ich
hoffe dass man hier ein bisschen heiß ab
mai youtube-channel huber johann feindt
ilike big apple zu
willkommen
einem feudalen stallungen meine
reittiere biete ich in form von
leasingverträgen an was so sparen sie
bares geld und kommen zudem in den
genuss einer jederzeitigen
mobilitätsgarantie suchen sie die etwas
passendes aus ich nehme den drachen
alter der drache lesen ich lese mir
einen drachen hab ich den jetzt irgendwo
ja das bin ich wahrscheinlich oder das
bin ich auch cool hier sind dungeons
weil ich mal hier dem modeportal 1 du
kannst täglich einmal durch das portal
geben und kämpfen die lebensenergie der
portal gegner regeneriert sich im zehn
punkte
wir können das auch komplett ohne gewalt
regeln da braucht jetzt auch nicht hier
damit irgendwie auch noch wenn du so
weitermachst mit dieser gegner bei den
ich seit ich hab ich auch schon erledigt
eigentlich stachel lachen
wie sieht der denn aussieht ich
gefährlich aus würde ich mal hier aber
hier kann ich jetzt zurück genau zurück
ich mal hier dieses was ist das denn das
was war das jetzt will mich einfach mal
besoffen
ich hab' ich möchte jetzt nicht im video
fünf minuten warten für so eine aufgabe
ach komm wir machen das einfach nur um
zu saufen dauert zwei minuten 30 sogar
nur
hitzefrei
denn jetzt schon wieder man ewig können
das doch ganz ganz ganz ruhig freunde
und das mistvieh ich ist erledigt und
alle sind beeindruckt von einer
heldentat ich habe diese heldentat nicht
getan um irgendwen zu beschützen oder
irgendwas zu machen
ich will einfach nur saufen ich möchte
einfach nur ein bierchen und das kriege
hier nicht man das war mein einziger
anreisen im spiel also was ich jetzt
durch dieses anzocken erfahren habe von
dem spiel beziehungsweise gelernt habe
es ist eigentlich recht cool für die die
auf solche spiele stehen denn ihr aber
bock hab das ganze mal zu testen findet
ihren link dazu in der beschreibung
es handelt quasi davon ihr macht euch
ein charakter irgendwie hat acht
verschiedene zur auswahl oder so könnte
ich den machen und dann könnt ihr halt
diese quests machen in der tabelle und
davon geht eure abenteuerlust runter
aber die könnt ihr euch wieder auflaufen
mit bier und ihr bekommt dann geld
berliner schafft und es gibt auch noch
sachen die euch kaufen könnt wie
ausdauer und stärke und was weiß ich und
arena online was das denn ich möchte
auch jetzt kämpfen die hier schon wieder
heiß das war knapp aber mit hinterlist
und schmutzigen tricks kulisse das wird
alles noch schmutziger tricks das war es
jetzt hier mit dem spiel ich hoffe es
hat mit dem video mit dem spiel war es
das jetzt nicht aber ich hoffe euch hat
das video gefallen getan habe ich meine
bewertung von wenn ihr einst von zwei
von diesen dingern den headsets die man
sich aussetzen kann oder so cool wenn er
in der bahn steht so schreibt einfach
ein kommentar mit eurem lieblingsessen
habe ich jetzt mal so rausgefunden da
werde ich davon welche auswählen
irgendwie irgendwo irgendwann wir sehen
uns dann wann anders